didn't choose to like move out when I  was 15. you know what I mean me and my  dad didn't have the best relationship so  like we would just get an argument over  the littlest things it just kind of like  got to the last straw when he was like  you should like leave the house  basically and I just called my friend  and I was like hi can you and your mom  pick me up and they picked me up I have  my backpack all my clothes in there so  then I just slept over at my friend's  house that night and it just continued  and continued and I just never went back  home and I'm so grateful that my friend  let me stay on our couch for two months  I like grinded my YouTube from that  point I was like I need to be able to  make my own money to be able to support  myself